although i continued to work when i took
drugs i didn't make my best work some of
the time i never really um
i never really
wanted to take drugs i just joined in
for the sake of it if i could go back to
when i first saw a line of cocaine i
would say no now
hi i'm elton john hi i'm charlie puth
and we'll be answering fans questions
for lad bible
who were your favorite musical artists
to listen to growing up well i grew up
in in
the late 40s and early 50s so there was
no rock and roll at that time i was
listening to
uh k star
johnny ray guy mitchell frankie lane nat
king cole and then of course it all
changed when i heard heartbreak hotel by
elvis presley and then little richard
and jerry lewis hammering the you know
the [ __ ] out of the piano and that's
when i decided i wanted to be like them
um
it was you know things changed so
radically when elvis came along in the
50s socially as well as musically and
then when the beatles happened in the
60s they even revolutionized things more
and musicians started to work with each
other and you know music musicians from
different genres would experiment with
other it was a wonderful time
i
grew up listening to
uh a hodgepodge of things
the carpenters james taylor and the
chronic by dr dre is the reason why i
want to produce music
those drums
which one of your songs are you most
proud of and why i'd say your song
because it was the first good song
i wrote my first hit and then i've never
got fed up with singing it and it's
lasted so you look at the chart and your
name is above people you've loved all
your life and respected you know i
looked at my our
your song at the elton john record and
it was above george harrison and i kept
looking at the billboard going this
can't be right i'm a i grew up with the
beatles this can't be right i mean you
never get over that that's a good song
i'd say see you again for me even though
it's not technically my song um but i
wrote it and came from a place of heart
do you have a favorite pair of
sunglasses
um
not really because i've got so many i
can choose
whatever mood i'm in
um i'm you know i'm very lucky to have
so much to choose from how many do you
have
oh god i'm not sure i mean it's in the
thousands it has to be yeah but i mean
i've been collecting them ever since um
it's in 1970 when i started wearing the
the stars and all the crazy glasses i
still have most of them what is your
go-to meal after a gig
it's very hard to eat after gig because
it's very bad to eat that late at night
so i might have a handful of almonds and
a glass of water which is really boring
whereas i'd love to have a pizza pizza
after a show is incredible i i like
having i don't do it as much anymore and
maybe one day i too will have some
almonds with water but i i i have a
weird fascination with getting off the
stage
um and just being by myself and having
personal pan pizzas and like eating like
a stack and like sleeve them
who is someone you would like to
collaborate with that you haven't
already oh you've collaborated with
everybody collaborating with most people
um sam fender
he's a british rock and roll artist
who's the best rock and roll artist
there is that he makes oasis sound like
um
um a ca palm court trio uh he's
brilliant in the spirit of not always
doing pop records and branching out in
the other fields i i i if yo yo ma and i
could write
uh something for him
and i don't even sing on the record and
maybe i don't even play piano on the
record but i get to construct a melody
with yo-yo ma
that's that's chill-inducing i would
love that i've done that yeah fine
yeah yeah yeah
yeah
to date is there any bit of your career
that you would change
yeah i wouldn't have taken as many drugs
definitely not although i continued to
work when i took drugs i didn't make my
best work some of the time i never
really
um
i never really
wanted to take drugs i just joined ian
for the sake of it and it became an
addiction and i became an addict an
alcoholic and uh
i've since you know learned my lesson
but i would if i could go back
to when i first saw a line of cocaine i
would say no now
i can't say i have any regrets maybe i
could have started earlier but i'm i'm
almost just happy that i kind of started
receiving like the amount of fame that i
had at like 24 years old i don't know if
i'd be able to handle it earlier on
who is your biggest inspiration
my husband david
without a question and my two children
but david yeah
you know i'm living with me is not easy
sometimes because artists can be very
moody and they have self-doubt and he's
very good at talking things over with me
and making me see that making me see
sense so if i didn't have him i don't
know where i would be i i wrote the
lyrics to after all about their
relationship because i remember speaking
to david and he said the words that you
probably don't even remember
inadvertently he said he said after all
that i knew that i was the perfect
manager and perfect partner for elton
sum up your career in one word
unexpected and the reason why i say that
is because i am i was for i was never
really a singer in my band of bluesology
and then when i started writing songs
nobody recorded them so i was forced to
sing the songs and so i became a singer
by accident great thing about life it
throws things at you that you totally
don't expect um my career and the
success of my career when it started in
1970 and exploded i never thought stole
that coming whatsoever charlie uh i
would say
a synonym of that surprising i
two was writing records that nobody
wanted to cut while i was in college and
uh
and the first record
that started off for me was cu again and
i just i'm so i was surprised that i was
able to successfully put jazz-ish chord
changes into pop music but then i
realized that you have been doing that
all along
my my bottom is getting sore from
pinching it so much i can't believe i
get to hang out with him it's not
getting sore from me pinching it by the
way no unfortunately not
oh my god
[Applause]
why jelly who came up with that as
disgusting